[Music]
22 minutes after the hour and just when
it seemed like le'veon bell was
potentially going to sit out the whole
season or at a minimum show up the
tuesday after week 10 the latest he
could
jeremy fowler of espn reports that bell
will show up in week seven that's the
steelers bye week sign the franchise
tender and bell plans to stay with the
steelers after that bell later told
fowler it sucks having to sit out
football i want to play i want to win
games and the playoffs but i've got to
take this stand knowing my worth and
knowing i can tear a ligament or get
surgery at any time i knew i couldn't
play 16 games with 400 or more touches
now peter we saw on
on sunday what can happen with one play
you can break your leg if you're earl
thomas he's still coming back belle is
and accepting the risk that he will
suffer the kind of injury that will keep
him from getting the kind of payday that
he wants so
i don't know
is this
bell making a calculated decision that
i'm gonna miss half the season and just
roll the dice on the second half or did
he just get to the point where he
decides i can't stay away anymore i want
to be back it sounds like he's he's
mainly decided i just want to be back
and play football
mike this is a calculated risk he's
basically saying
i'm going to get paid for a little more
than half the season and i'm going to
play for a little more than half the
season remember
the nfl distributes paychecks in 17 part
increments not 16. so theoretically and
i wonder if the steelers would grieve
this
if he signs his tender on the monday of
the bye week
theoretically i would think i don't know
exactly what the rules are
but i would think he's going to get paid
in that bye week you know uh basically
800 whatever it is 853 000
that's a pretty expensive check uh you
know for the steelers to write when the
team is not playing and i don't even
think the team will be practicing that
week so that's one part of it
the other part i find really interesting
is that right now james connor has taken
his place as 81 touches through four
games so that means basically that the
steelers are giving the le'veon bell
character in their little mini series
20 touches a game that adds up to about
325 a year in general okay and i'm not
saying that this is exact right but the
only point that i'm making is that
you never know
like le'veon bell says i don't want to
come back for 400 touches first of all
i don't think there's any way anyway
with a healthy james connor
that if le'veon bell was there for 16
games fully healthy that he would have
ever had 400 touches i just i don't see
the steelers doing that i see it being
290 to
150 something like that that's just it's
an absolute guess
but the second thing is mike have you
looked at the steelers schedule
the first two games out of the buy
cleveland
and at baltimore
so le'veon bell comes back all of a
sudden it's no longer a gimme game
against the browns
he comes back to play the browns and
then they go to the ravens in what i
think is going to be an absolute total
must win game for the cleveland bro for
the pittsburgh steelers
here's another issue to keep in mind and
this came up back in early september
when he didn't show up before the final
roster cuts by rule after that if he
decides to sign his franchise tender he
and the steelers must decide in advance
what he will be paid if the steelers put
him on roster exempt status which they
can do for two regular season games i
don't know whether or not they're going
to insist on doing that when he shows up
in week seven but if they have the
ability to put him on roster exempt
status for two games and they're in a
bye week in week seven and they have to
agree what he's going to be paid while
he's on roster exempt status while
they're getting him in shape
that could get very interesting he may
have every intention to show up that
week and then he shows up and kevin
colbert says to him okay we got to
figure out what we're going to pay you
while you're on roster exempt we're
putting you on a two-week roster
exemption and he's like what are you
talking about well we're not going to
pay 855 000 a week if we're going to
exercise our right to put you on roster
exempt status so we have to figure out
how much we're going to pay you that's
the side of this we don't know yet peter
because we don't know whether or not the
steelers are going to roll out the red
carpet they've been trying to trade him
so how are they going to react to this
that remains to be seen but it could
still get a little messy when he shows
up
i expect it to be messy there's no way
this is going to be clear or clean i
don't think it's going to be an earl
atomic earl thomas seahawks type of
messi but i do think there's a good
chance it'll be messy and mike i just
keep saying
the steelers at that point are going to
be in must win mode and i think mike
tomlin's attitude is going to be we'll
let bygones be by guns we got to beat
the browns and the ravens hi i'm mike
tarico and thanks for watching make sure
to hit subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports